a
stole my life Robin would open the door
and come out and he'd find this letter
and I was right next to Gus next to the
camera and I would say said you know
Sean if the professor calls about that
job tell him sorry I had to go see about
a girl we had scripted that he just kind
of sits there and takes it in and
realizes that my character is gone and
he didn't say anything he just kind of
took that moment and in true Robin
fashion we did 60 takes you know like we
just left the camera rolling and he kept
coming out and kept coming out and he
did something different every single
time the one that's in the movie he just
said son of a he stole my lime and
I remember when he said son of a
he stole my line I was with Gus Van Sant
the director we were both next to the
camera and I remember grabbing him like
this like shaking him like he felt
intense up like we both knew we were
like holy like what a line like how
did we not think of that like that is
great obviously it was the whole movie
was leading to that line like clearly we
thought this little thing out just like
we planned because we knew that was it
the second he said it I had to go see
about a girl